this is a scene people in Beijing hoped
they would never have to witness again
workers sealing off one of the city's
largest food markets after a resurgence
of coronavirus infections there and it's
not the only step being taken security
forces have been called in they're
setting up checkpoints are making sure
the thousands of residents living in the
vicinity of the market are following
orders to stay indoors and not leave
their homes authorities say they
determined to contain the outbreak
district was immediately put on an
emergency wartime like footing and we
set up a field headquarters to deal with
the situation at the wholesale markets
and the surrounding communities in line
with the principle of putting the
people's safety and health first Tai Chi
from B Guan each washer in a measure of
their concern restrictions elsewhere in
the city are also being reintroduced
plans to reopen primary schools on
Monday have been put on hold and all
sporting events and tourist activities
have been suspended several other
markets have also been closed
temporarily as a precaution the new
cases are the first local transmissions
of the virus in nearly two months one
reports suggest they may have come from
a contaminated surface used for chopping
fish but investigators are still
scrambling to find the source they're
also planning to carry out more than
10,000 tests on anyone who's been in
contact with the market the hope is this
will stop the spread more than anything
though it shows the challenges ahead for
other countries where outbreaks are also
thought to be under control
let's cross over now to correspondent
Matias Bolinger who's recently returned
to China is currently in quarantine in
Tianjin but tears what do we know about
this new cluster of cases yeah it
appeared in the biggest wholesale market
food wholesale market in Beijing a huge
market that supplies the whole city with
fresh foods
the authorities have released very very
early that they found a sample of the
virus on a board used to cutting
imported sermon as they put it but by
now we know that it has been found on 40
other objects in the market and forty
five people have been have tested
positive it is not clear what the
origins of the virus were how it arrived
at that market but authorities have been
quick to shut down huge parts of the
surrounding areas they have delayed
schools to the reopening of schools and
all kinds of measures are being put up
that has just been disappeared from
Beijing streets all kinds of checkpoints
etc are being quickly put up again these
are the first domestically transmitted
cases in Beijing in almost two months
people satisfied with the way
authorities have been handling the
crisis and in particular this cluster
it's hard to say because this cluster is
very new and we're getting new
information all the time it's just been
a few hours since we have known that
it's more than just a few cases but 45
is as the number is right now in general
I would say that people have been
confident in the reply of that in the
measures that the government has used to
bring the numbers down in the past few
months many people are saying that China
is now a safe place have been saying
until today I should rather say so it's
hard to say at the moment how this will
play out how these measures will play
out what will be the result the people
these support in general I would say the
majority although we never know really
there's a lot of distortion due to
censorship due to non existing opinion
polls but I would say the majority of
people certainly support harsh measures
quick measures tough measures on any
outbreak correspondent Matias billing
are speaking to us from Tianjin
chyna thanks very much for the update
now let me bring you up to date with
some of the other latest developments in
the pandemic Poland has reopened its
borders to its EU neighbors after being
closed for nearly three months
tourists from Germany Czech Republic
Slovakia and Lithuania can now enter the
country border controls with non EU
neighbors are also being relaxed Greece
is preparing to admit foreign visitors
from Monday with its economy heavily
reliant on tourism but flights from
coronavirus hotspots such as the UK will
not be allowed in while India has
reported its biggest single-day rise in
coronavirus cases nearly 12,000
infections were recorded within 24 hours
taking the total to more than 300
thousands